It’s been said that knowledge is power,
and when it comes to SCP-2440, that might
really be the case.
Like many of the anomalies and entities that
have been kept on file by the SCP Foundation,
SCP-2440 - the being known as The Sealed King
- is a malicious creature of untold, devastating
power.
The key word there is “untold”, and we
mean it in the most literal sense: You cannot
know about SCP-2440, it must remain untold.
Unless, of course, you have at least Level
4 clearance.
You do have the right level of clearance,
don’t you?
We really would hate to have to break out
the amnestics and wipe your memory at the
end of this video.
Assuming that you do have adequate clearance,
then it is time to introduce you to SCP-2440,
known to some as The Sealed King, or Xiolt-la
to its friends - if it had any friends that
is.
If you are familiar with the likes of the
infamous Hanged King or the even more infamous
Scarlet King, then you will have heard the
term “eldritch being” thrown around before.
An eldritch abomination is an almost godlike
entity, one which does not adhere to the natural
laws of the universe as we understand them.
Their disturbing otherworldliness is almost
indescribable to any mortal person.
It is a description that can be easily used
to define SCP-2440, along with the words “Keter
Class Anomaly” and “existentially terrifying.”
The Sealed King is an extra dimensional entity,
a being that inhabits a plain of existence
far outside the physical reality of our own
universe.
While the creature’s physical appearance
has yet to be observed by any in this dimension,
some have depicted it as resembling a gigantic
being with a mass of squid-like tentacles,
along with a glowing humanoid form in its
center.
What makes SCP-2440 such a formidable threat,
however, is not just the creature’s immense
size.
One of SCP-2440’s core abilities is the
power to influence and manipulate the minds
of mortal beings.
But this isn’t as simple as The Sealed King
choosing one person from our universe and
driving them like a remote controlled car.
SCP-2440’s influence is spread memetically.
By manipulating data and information, SCP-2440
slips its memetic agents into texts, images,
even spoken phrases and other audio stimuli.
Think of it like subliminal messaging, or
product placement.
Imagine for a moment that you see a character
on a TV show eating a certain brand of black
and white sandwich cookie, and that makes
you decide that you want to go to the store
and buy some delicious black and white sandwich
cookies to enjoy for yourself.
That idea was planted in your head by something
you saw, and it had an influence on your behavior.
SCP-2440 operates on a very similar principle,
but with one key difference.
Once enough people become aware of it, SCP-2440
will use those to subtly spread its influence,
controlling the actions of those it manages
to infect, and its hold becomes stronger the
further they spread the knowledge of The Sealed
King.
To put it plainly, the more people that become
aware of The Sealed King’s existence, the
more powerful this eldritch abomination becomes.
The range and scope of SCP-2440’s abilities
varies depending on the quantity of people
its influence has been memetically spread
to.
According to research by the SCP Foundation,
if two hundred people or less have been infected,
then these individuals will demonstrate an
increased interest in media belonging to the
horror, science fiction or fantasy genres,
whether this be films, books or images that
fall into one of these categories.
Exposure to these desired materials is believed
to increase the spread of The Sealed King’s
influence.
If the number of infected individuals climbs
to between 201 and 500 people, then SCP-2440
has been known to take direct control of a
single infected person.
This control is somewhat limited though, with
The Sealed King only able to maintain a connection
with the controlled host for half an hour.
During this time, the infected person will
attempt to infect further people by creating
works that contain subtle details about the
nature of SCP-2440.
Historically, when infection levels have reached
this phase, Foundation researchers have been
able to communicate with SCP-2440 through
conversation with its host.
The creature displays a very hostile attitude
towards humanity, and has been quite open
with the fact that its sole purpose is to
continue infecting individuals until it is
able to manifest physically in our reality
without the need for a host, something that
feels like it’s right out of the evil eldritch
entity playbook.
When infection of that knowledge spreads to
up to 1,500 people, SCP-2440 becomes able
to take full control of another infected individual,
without the previous limitations.
By making them fully subservient, it will
then use this person to speak simultaneously
to any and all that have been infected with
information regarding The Sealed King.
Next, if up to 10,000 people become infected,
more of SCP-2440’s abilities start to influence
this dimension.
The creature is known to be able to distort
and reshape reality, though at this point
SCP-2440 still needs to control a host.
But even though its powers and abilities have
increased, at this stage the creature shows
no interest in actually using them, and its
focus still remains on using its human host
to spread its memetic agents, furthering the
infection.
Once the number of people infected by SCP-2440
through subliminal, memetic information surpasses
ten thousand, The Sealed King is able to manifest
its true form outside of a human host, for
a maximum time frame of one hour.
This is the point of no return, as SCP-2440’s
reality bending powers are dramatically increased.
The methods that would have previously kept
the creature at bay will cease to be effective
and it can take direct control of up to one
thousand of those it has infected.
Normally, the SCP Foundation limits the number
of people permitted to know about SCP-2440
to one hundred cleared personnel.
This is achieved through the use of amnestics.
Given that SCP-2440 is a creature that grows
stronger the more people know about it, these
drugs certainly seem like a viable way of
keeping that number nice and low.
But once infection numbers reach ten thousand?
That’s when amnestics are just no longer
enough.
Based on the information about The Sealed
King that is available to them, SCP Foundation
personnel have projected that if the number
of people infected by SCP-2440 ever reached
as high as 100,000 or more, the creature would
likely be able to manifest outside a host
for longer, possibly up to two hours.
It is also believed that SCP-2440 would be
capable of creating dimensional portals, either
inviting anomalies from other universes into
our own, or simply creating its own anomalous
creatures.
By this point, any and all infected individuals
would be fully under The Sealed King’s control.
Finally, if a million people were to become
infected, SCP-2440 would most likely achieve
its ultimate goal.
The eldritch creature would be able to fully
and permanently manifest itself in our dimension,
in its true form, most likely leading to an
XK Class End of the World Scenario.
Fortunately, through the dispensing of amnestics,
the SCP Foundations have managed to prevent
such a scenario from coming to pass.
Additionally, containment teams are regularly
sent to investigate any reported awareness
of SCP-2440, and any infected individuals
are either treated with memory-altering drugs,
or simply terminated.
The entity has been known to spread its influence
through text too though, and even the documents
within the SCP Foundation’s archives aren’t
safe.
The Foundation attempts to keep any links
to The Sealed King within other SCP files
hidden to avoid a spread of knowledge about
this extra dimensional eldritch abomination.
However, while only a hundred members of authorized
SCP personnel are aware of SCP-2440, the Foundation
isn’t the only organization aware of this
being’s existence.
A group calling themselves the “Children
of God” is comprised of individuals previously
infected with the knowledge of SCP-2440’s
existence, and has supposedly been around
even longer than the Foundation has.
These people worship The Sealed King as a
deity, and seek to infect others with the
same information that the creature uses to
influence them.
Carrying out the whims of this extra dimensional
threat, the Children of God attempt to “spread
the word” as it were, by any means available
to them.
The Foundation considers any member of the
Children of God to be highly dangerous and
containment teams are advised to either capture
them on sight, or use lethal force to terminate
them.
The Children of God were previously based
in a compound somewhere in the United States
and during an assault on their base, the Foundation
was able to recover documents that described
the possible origin of SCP-2440.
According to these documents, at the very
dawn of time, old gods emerged from an empty
abyss of nothingness, otherwise referred to
as Mother Void.
This entity granted life across the universe,
all other realities and every conceivable
dimension.
However, the story detailed in the Children
of God’s legend claims that the old gods
were “fickle, twisted, and brutal things”
with “no purity in them”.
It seems to suggest that the old gods were
similar entities to SCP-2440, capable of bending
and reshaping reality, and apparently did
so purely for their own amusement within the
newly-created universe.
These old gods created creatures in their
own image, toying with the fabric of reality
like children with blocks, building and destroying
at will.
Before long, the old gods began to turn on
each other, focusing their natural jealousy
on their siblings that had been born of the
void.
The firstborn of the Void and Chaos, a being
called Ma’tol, coveted the creations of
his fellow old gods, and flooded the newly
created worlds with a rampaging army of vile,
grotesque beasts he had made.
As Ma’tol attempted to kill his various
siblings, the other old gods retaliated and
sent the universe into a period of darkness
where “the blood of young life flowed like
water.”
However, none of the old gods could ever die,
only be forgotten, but they had created so
many creatures to serve them and fulfil their
purposes that it seemed impossible this would
ever happen.
The Children of God’s documents then describe
Xiolt-la, or SCP-2440 as he is otherwise known.
Apparently the first born of Mother Void and
an entity called Father Light, SCP-2440 is
also referred to by many reverent titles such
as Lord of the Gods, Devourer of the Impure
and Savior of Life.
Being born of both light and the darkness
of the void, Xiolt-la was considered to be
a true god, and according to the creature’s
followers, did not set about creating life,
but perfecting it.
The old gods turned on Xiolt-la, his half
siblings attacking him with the armies and
monstrosities they had created.
However, some of these creatures turned on
their masters in service of SCP-2440 instead.
After generations of warfare between SCP-2440
and the old gods, Xiolt-la finally vanquished
Ma’tol in single combat that lasted ten
thousand years and laid waste to countless
worlds, almost tearing the universe apart.
Eventually prevailing, Xiolt-la cast his siblings
down into oblivion.
But as he did so, Ma’tol cursed him, banishing
SCP-2440 from the universe, implied in these
documents to have been our very own reality.
The Children of God venerate the creature
as their lord and savior, with more of their
documents claiming that this “king of all
mankind” is wrongfully sealed away.
They believe their Sealed King is returning,
destined to reappear in this dimension and
lay waste to our reality.
Whether this is truly the origin of SCP-2440,
or just what the entity wishes its infected
disciples to believe is unclear.
Whatever the case, we suggest you quickly
forget everything you know about SCP-2440
for your own safety.
Now check out “SCP-001 - The Scarlet King”
and “SCP-2845 - Alien God Crash Lands On
Our Planet - The Deer” for more entities
that could destroy everything we know and
love in a heartbeat.